Let's look at how we can use
HTML headings effectively
to recreate the experience
we saw in Victor's video.
First I'd like to reiterate Rob's
point that DOM order matters,
which is also item 1.3.2
on the webbing checklist.
Rob showed how it matters for
focus order, but it also matters for
the order read by the screen reader.
In Victor's demo, you might have
noticed how the heading list
followed the DOM order and
not the visual order of the page.
That is actually true for
screen readers in general.
Since the screen reader,
like any assistive technology,
is interacting with
the accessibility tree,
which is based directly on the DOM tree,
the order a screen reader is going to
perceive will be directly
based on the DOM order.
Think of the page as perceived
by desktop screen reader uses at
almost losing its second dimension.
It's all serialized into
a single stream of content.
I can use a little snippet of
JavaScript which you can copy from
the instructor notes to list out
the headings in the console.
I can use a little snippet of
JavaScript, which you can copy from
the instructor notes,
to list out the headings in the console.
We have one H1 in this list,
telling us the page's main topic.
This is also echoed in
the page's title in the header.
So when switching tabs or windows,
users know what page they're on.
Then we have a series of H2s.
Which include both page
structure things like contents,
as well as article sections.
Between some of those H2's, we also
have H3's indicating subsections.
Some of these are in
the article contents, but
some are also in
the surrounding page contents.
Within navigation menu there are things
like personal tools and languages.
This page only goes down to H3, but we
do have built in heading tags going all
the way down to H6 for
very complex or long documents.
Using headings to lay out page structure
like this is mentioned in several
web aim checklist items.
2.4.10 states individual sections of
content are designated using headings
where appropriate.
1.3.1 mentions semantic markup is
used to designate headings age one.
2.4.1 mentions heading structure
as a sufficient technique for
bypassing blocks of content.
And 2.4.6 discusses some details for
writing useful headings.
If you are really watching closely,
Ella, you might have noticed
that not all of these headings
are visible on the screen.
Wikipedia is using a technique where
they place some headings off screen to
make them visible only to screen reader
uses and other assistive technology.
For complex applications, this can be
a good way to accommodate headings when
the visual design doesn't require or
even have room for a visible heading.
However, it's important not to go
overboard with this technique.
Remember that assistive technology users
may well be able to see the screen.
So going too far down the path of
creating screen reader only content,
can actually create a worse
user experience for some users.
Besides which, it can create
a maintenance headache when it comes to
things like internationalization.